Carol is a survivor
she has already suffered two strokes I'm
by myself there is nobody here to
actually be with me or to comfort me or
to to administer any kind of help
so when she started feeling dizzy and
losing her eyesight for a third time she
feared the worst it took about an hour
or maybe an hour and a half before the
ambulance actually arrived and what was
interesting was when it was that they
did arrive and they understood about the
history and the fact that I had a
headache they then blew lighted me to
hospital
this time it was a false alarm but heart
attacks and strokes should be attended
to within 18 minutes and any delays can
have life-changing consequences and
ambulances are taking longer than ever
as hospitals run out of space
we currently have 13 000 patients in
hospital who are medically fit and able
to be discharged of whom many of whom
will need support with social care or
domiciliary care at home and because of
the challenges in offering social care
we're not able to discharge those
patients okay thank you very much
this is one of the solutions designed to
ease that crippling pressure
they call this Command Center a winter
War Room there's no battle but lives are
at stake assistant there's some
pressures down in East Kent from here
real-time data from Seven acute
hospitals across Kent is used to manage
ambulance response times and patient
discharges what it allows us to do is to
balance so where there's a particular
point of pressure in one part of the
geography and a bit less in somewhere
else we can switch resources seamlessly
in the way that you've seen and make
sure that those waiting times come down
it's a strategy pioneered during the
pandemic now they hope it can protect
the NHS this winter
the target for response times for
ambulances attending the most serious
emergencies that's a category one call
is seven minutes the national average is
about 10 minutes but here in Kent in
Seven Oaks that weight can be up to 13
minutes so will a command center like
this one have any real impact on those
response times
they believe so Health leaders think
technology and a fully joined up Health
and Care system means they have a better
chance not just here but in 41 other War
rooms across the country
and for patients like Carol it could
save her life Ashish Josh is Sky News in
Kent